in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape and I'm Lloyd
joined in the studio by dr. dieter
quince he said some knowledge is an
expert for sleeping and sleeping
disorders hello and welcome to the show
hi chronic lack of sleep seems to be
quite dangerous as we saw on the report
and so like how to take diabetes
depression I said well the mechanisms
behind are not well known until now but
over the last 12 months a couple of
reports came in that are quite quite
informative one of them is an old
hypothesis that we just get rid of all
the toxins that developed you in the day
that is really diluted you a night that
is one and second there's a studies
shown that on the molecular mechanism
gene expression is changed in about
one-third of all the genes even if you
have just a shortage of sleep from eight
to six hours just over a couple of days
so we start to find the mechanisms that
are behind there quite dramatic so it
doesn't take a long time for me to not
get enough sleep and really get ill well
whether we get ill that fast we do not
know but we can see the changes so even
short-term sleep restriction leads to
these changes whether that actually
needs to disorder then and how long that
takes we do not know but short time
sleep restriction happens nearly every
day I mean I'm a father got two kids so
I'm restricted to my sleep pattern a lot
of times can I catch up with my sleep so
getting a nap next day well we do not
know that as well whoever is awoken by
the alarm clock most obviously didn't
get enough sleep and most of us do not
have this stored short-term sleep
researcher what we do in that for 10 or
20 years sleep restriction for two or
three hours and that seems to really
change your health but how whether we
can catch
a short term sleep research and we do
not know okay and restriction of sleep
can lead to serious consequences and
diseases but diseases itself can lead to
sleep restriction sleep problems like
thyroid functions many of my patients
and my GP office come to me and say
perhaps dr. IM sick because I don't get
enough sleep this is true yes it's going
boast direction of course any any change
in the nervous system psychotic to hold
a neurologic disorder they do not sleep
so all of them go along with sleep
disorder but it can go vice versa yes
and and when do I need as a patient to
see a doctor well as three major things
first of all it is yes snoring and apnea
and secondly if you jump out a bit
during item so if you have motor
activity during sleep then you should
see your doctor and the third one is non
restorative sleep it's not problems
falling asleep or maintaining sleep this
is not the major thing we look at the
functions of sleep so if you function
well during the day then everything is
ok but if you do not function well and
you do not know why that is and you
should go should go see you sleep doctor
and asleep doctors the right person to
go to it's not the GP you're leading a
sleep laboratory so so what kind of
diagnosis all doing it we do not have as
many sleep doctors so I cannot read all
of them so you start out with a general
practitioner but if that doesn't help
then you may go to psychiatrists and if
that doesn't help then you should see
really asleep doctor what's your
personal opinion about taking sleeping
pills well first of all it's good that
we have them but on the other hand we
ought to get rid of them because they're
not specific they they induce a state
which is not really natural sleep so
most of them do not fulfill the
functions of sleep and so they have a
hangover in the next morning it's good
that we have them but we need more
specific books and are those in the
pipeline of the researchers that we get
more specific directions but at least
one specific drug is is in the pipeline
and we all hope that it's coming this
year and I do believe that's going to be
fantastic that's a specific drug
and which probably will help in lots of
patient so we will look forward to that
and until then what about home remedies
like the vendor or valerian and can I
help with those kind of well there's no
specific scientific proof that that you
can say in general that it helps but in
some people it does help and as long as
it helps take okay we got a lot of
viewer questions I mean the topic of
sleep affects nearly everybody so we got
a viewer question from Indonesia Aviano
vannatta from Indonesia she has taken
sleeping pills for years and now she
switched to meditation and after she
switched asleep is fine can this be
explained with meditation continue with
meditation continue and are there any
scientific research that backs this up
I'm not aware of any of them okay and
remo Chevy from Andorra and he often
wakes up during the night and he says
that that really doesn't bother him at
all he stays awake and then falls asleep
again and and he just want to know does
he need to be concerned no he doesn't
need to be concerned asleep can
individually be quite different some of
people just need for hours others need
10 hours and that is individually most
important thing how do you feel during
the day so if the functions of sleep are
fulfilled don't bother and don't worry
about any kind of change in sleep so
some people are explaining it lack of
sleep and other ones are sleeping too
much my god bajas from Chile has a
daughter and the daughter is 21 21 years
old and she's a bright student she rides
and her daughter M sleeps at least for
12 hours a night during daytime she's
unimpaired overnight I'm she's leaving
for 12 hours and mrs. bra codes now
wants to know if Eddie noids in the nose
channel of her daughter can be the cause
of this yeah but prolonged sleep well
first thing like i told before if they
doing find you in the day it sounds ok
12 hours sounds a lot yes these these
other nights could be a reason for
longer sleep so if people have something
like 12 hours to sleep you should see a
sleep darker maybe the quality of your
sleep is impaired and that's why you
need that much sleep when
you could be much better off with eight
hours sleep when you change that but I
cannot tell you that just here so one
it's one one possible solution so Miss
Broca's daughter should see an ENT
doctor or sleep specialist to check this
out one last question Jung Lu from China
wants to know what kind of relaxation
techniques you would recommend for
falling asleep whatever helps there but
relaxation in the evening is most
important you should not do stressful
things before you go to sleep and you
should not discuss your life with your
partner in the last five minutes before
following your sleep you need to calm
down in any way so put yourself into a
sleepy mode and then go to sleep that's
it thanks so much for being with us in
the studio thank you thank you
you